Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill, four-burner gas grill, on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $49. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies last, price invalid May 14th or May 27th. U.S. only exclusions apply.
See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. Have you ever raced through a compelling novel in a day, then found yourself sad because you're not ready to say goodbye to the characters? Or maybe you've set aside a full weekend to binge watch the new season of your favorite TV show. We humans spend a lot of time in fictional worlds, and researchers have long wondered why. What draws us to the make-believe of a novel, a TV show, or a movie? What makes a fictional world so fascinating that it can spawn on a movie series, a theme park, or fan conventions? Are there some types of stories or characters
who are especially likely to gather devoted fans? And how does reading or watching fiction affect us? Does reading a novel give us any insight into the minds and emotions of real people? And can it change how we see the world? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science
and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is an expert on both studying and writing fiction. Dr. Jennifer Lynn Barnes is a novelist and psychologist who published her first novel at age 19. She's the author of more than 20 critically acclaimed young adult novels, including the New York Times best-selling series The Inheritance Games, which has sold more than 4 million copies. For many years, Dr. Barnes balanced her writing career with her work as a research psychologist.
She holds a PhD in psychology. from Yale University and was a professor at the University of Oklahoma for nearly a decade. Her research focused on the psychology of fiction, including what makes people love stories and how fiction affects our social cognition. Dr. Barnes recently left academia to write full-time. Dr. Barnes, thank you for joining me today. I'm so thrilled to be here. I love talking psychology, especially now that I'm not doing psychology on a daily basis. I will take any excuse to get to talk about it. Well, then let's start with your background. As I said for many years, you balanced a dual career as a novelist and a psychology professor. What drew you to both of those things? How did you manage to do both for as long as you did?
I think what drew me to both of them is really very similar. I'm interested in people. I'm interested in relationships and how our minds work and how we become who we are, the effect of development on who we are. And I think that's a lot of why people get into writing oftentimes. is because you get to dive so deep into the heads of fictional characters. And a lot of us, when we're right, we're kind of understanding how all of this is working. You get to create those relationships. You get to dive so deep into another person's head in a way you never get to do in reality. So I think I was drawn to sort of the internal aspects of characters' minds from the time I was a child in reading books. I would get lost in books and television shows
and very involved in fictional worlds. And then one day I discovered, hey, the best thing in the world is if every time something's happening in a story and you're like, gee, I hope this happens next. If you're the writer, that's exactly what can happen next. And then the flip side of that is on psychology. You know, I was drawn to understand the human mind
and groups and relationships and development. So I think it was actually the same just underlying interest in people and how we work that drew me to both. In terms of kind of balancing the two worlds, I had an advantage in that I didn't know what it was like to be an adult who didn't do both of those things. So I started trying to write novels when I was still in high school. The novel I wrote when I was 19, which is the first book I sold, was actually the seventh book I wrote. It takes a while to actually get good enough at writing books to sell one. And meanwhile, I was starting my freshman year in college. I was taking psychology classes. And so I went through undergrad. I got involved
in research labs. And I just fell in love with the pure science of psychology, asking questions and getting to actually determine answers. Like there's a question I don't know the answer to. I can design something. I can figure out an answer. Maybe I'll be surprised, have new theories, just like the cheer process of it all. I absolutely loved. And so then I just, I wrote my first five books while I was still in undergrad doing all of the psychology and cognitive science stuff. Then I graduated and I knew I wanted to keep doing research. So I did a master's and then a PhD and then eventually became a professor. And the University of Oklahoma created this wonderful unique position for me where they actually split me. So I was half in the psychology department. And that's where my research.
lab was, but they also let me teach writing courses over in the professional writing department. So I actually had a full dual appointment in two different departments. I earned tenure in both departments. And then my lab studied the psychology of fiction. So it was like all these different things, teaching fiction, writing fiction, studying the science of it. It all just worked together really, really well. And there was a lot of synergy between the different things. So what is it about fiction and stories that we find so compelling? I mean, most people don't write fiction, but almost all of us consume it, whether it's books or TV or movies. Why do we spend all this time and money to get so emotionally invested in things that are not real?
That is the question that has fascinated me for so long, because I always thought as a writer, if you can answer that question, If you can know why are we as a species so driven to fictional stories, then you can use whatever that theory is to predict exactly what kinds of stories people should like. And so what I did for a long time is this is actually a hotly debated issue in evolutionary psychology and some domains of social psychology. There are even like sort of some domains of like literary criticism that are into it, media psychology, sociology. There's all these different theories out there. Even philosophers have asked this question of why are we so into fiction and why can it affect us? And so what I did for years is I just read up on all of these different theories about fiction. And then so the answer is there are a lot of different competing theories on this.
there's no one definitive answer. But what I did as a writer is I went through each theory and I was like, well, if I can't tell you which theory for sure is true, why don't I just list out some of the predictions every theory makes about what we'd like in stories and then see what happens if I put all of those things in one book. So for example, some of the theories that I found as a writer that when I hit the notes in those theories, they tend to resonate with readers. They tend to sell more copies and all of that. So one big one is what I'd call gossip theory. So one of my old advisors, Paul Bloom, suggested this in his book, How Pleasure Works. And he said, thinks that a liking for fictional stories co-ops sort of an evolutionarily hardwired liking for gossip. And fiction is
just gossip about people who happen to be make-believe. And even though we, know their make-believe, maybe deep down we don't really feel like they are, or maybe our brains, if you think about something like television, like if you see someone in front of you, once a week, or for 20 hours at a time, you're seeing their faces, you're watching them going through their day-to-day lives, you know all of the stuff about them. Even though you know they're not real, you might feel like they're real. And so, you know, that would just suggest that fiction is just tapping the gossip button essentially over and over again. So what predictions does this make about the kinds of stories we might like?
That's something like I like to do when I'm coming up with book ideas. I'll say, does it pass the gossip test? So is it the stuff of gossip? For the inheritance games, I actually used this. I was coming up with book ideas specifically tailored to gossip theory. And the prompt I was using is what could happen to an ordinary teenage girl that would get the entire world talking about her overnight. So, like, not just the people at her high school, not just her town.
I wanted, like, front-page news. Everyone in the whole world is gossiping about you at once. And it took me days to find something that was actually good that could happen to you. A lot of the things I came up with, I write mystery thrillers. So I'm like, oh, I came up with some dark stuff, but I wanted something kind of light and fluffy and fun. What good thing could happen to you? And I came up with a few things, but the one that really stuck,
is a famous billionaire dies and he leaves you all his money. And no one has any idea why, because you didn't even know the guy. I'm like, that passes the gossip test because everyone would be like, why did this billionaire just leave $42 billion to this random 17-year-old from Connecticut? I was like, that passes the gossip test in a big way. So that's what told me like, oh, that would be a great book to write because it passes the gossip test. And then in the writing of the books, I look through a lot of,
of other theories. So, for example, there are theories that were drawn to fiction because we are drawn to the mind of others. So very much the reasons that I started writing fiction might also have a role to play in why we like fiction. So we're driven as a species to get inside the heads of others. We're always mentalizing. You can't even watch most of us like an animation with like rectangles and circles without
attributing mental states to them. We sort of over attribute mental states where a mentally obsessed species. But fiction is one of the only domains that you actually can get inside someone else's head. We feel like we know what's going on in other people's heads all the time. But we can't ever actually be in someone else's head except for fiction. And so there are researchers out there who think fiction makes us better at understanding people. So people like David Kidd and colleagues in the English literary criticism domain, Lisa Sunshine, who really deal with this idea of fiction and theory of mind and how it appeals to our desire to get inside other people's heads,
but also might actually make it better with us. So that predicts that we would love books, that one are all about mental states, emotions, second order theory of mind. So I actually have a little list from the developmental literature of all the different milestones. So I'm like, okay, the books have to prove secrets and lies. And he thinks that she thinks. And, you know, purposeful deception, knowledge and ignorance, hidden emotions. So I go through all these different elements and really make sure that the books are hitting on all cylinders for theory of mind. I actually did a whole book series that I did that much like Inheritance Games was inspired by gossip.
theory when my prior series was called the naturals. And it's basically a teenage criminal minds about an FBI think tank that uses teenagers to profile serial killers. And they mostly are supposed to be working cold cases. They're teenagers. So they're always creeping on to active cases. But there, I made it so that each of the quote unquote naturals was like one in a billion, very, very top percentile at some aspect of theory of mind. So there's an emotion reader. There's a dissection detector. There are a couple profilers.
And then as you read the books, it's actually teaching the psychological science of doing all of those things. My thought was, if we really are interested in fiction because it teaches us to get inside the minds of others, a book that's explicitly about learning how to get inside the minds of others should be appealing to audiences. And then a third theory I work with a lot was one put forth by Stephen Pinker in his book, How the Mind Works, where he kind of looks at, you know, all this debate about is fiction an evolutionary adaptation? Is it a byproduct of something else? And he says that, you know,
one of his theories, or at least his early theory of fiction, was that fiction is essentially cheesecake. We don't wander around saying, oh, my gosh, it's such a mystery. Why do humans like cheesecake. Well, we like cheesecake because we evolved like sugar and fat and clever human chefs. We're like, what if we put a ton of sugar and a ton of fat and the exact same thing? And then it becomes cheesecake. And he thinks fiction at least partially operates in much the same way. So why do we like fiction? Well, we're hardwired to find a bunch of different things pleasurable. And clever authors take all of those pleasures and they cream their books full of them. so that there's just sort of these pleasure buttons that fiction is pushing over and over and over and over again.
You think about something like television and most television shows are filled with beautiful people and maybe beautiful places. And so a few years ago when I was on maternity leave with my second child, I made my sort of project that I did while I was rocking a baby and feeding a baby. I was looking up what do I think some of these like really compelling possibly hardwired play? pleasures are, and I just made a list of them. I like, so what are pleasures that are early arising in development that you see cross-culturally, that perhaps have a neurological basis that's been studied. And so I just did this deep dive in the literature looking for different things and came up with a list of, okay, if pleasure theory is right, what buttons can I push?
And so there are things like beauty is one, wealth with a preference for high levels of wealth, power is a big one, so more power, more dominance. Competition, at least where you might be hardwired to pay very close attention to competitions between others. I put on there a safe danger. So, again, something, if not pleasurable, at least were wired to pay attention to these dangerous things. It's safe because it's fictional.
So you think about something like, you know, a fictional horror movie, you're not actually going to get hurt. and there's all of this philosophy and psychology on that, certain kinds of touch and warmth and physical sensations. So I had this sort of list of these things and I'm like, okay, I'm going to try and cram as much of all of this into a book as I possibly can. And that book was also the inheritance games. You'll notice it's basically called Wealth Competition. I even wanted the title to hit the buttons that I thought might matter. and then making sure that I'll actually do an inventory of each chapter I write and be like
what pleasures are in this chapter. And so those are just three of the theories that I've done a lot with. There are four more that are kind of in the play when I'm trying to go through different things. I actually wrote up a giant workbook for myself that's about 27 pages long that I go through. And when I'm revising a book, I go through and I see how I'm rating. on all these different things that these theories predict we would like in stories. But that's an amazing level of analysis that you've gone through over the years. And how has it changed the way that you write?
If you go back and you look at the novels that you wrote when you were much younger before you had gone through all of this, did you sort of instinctively include some of these things? Because I think a lot of novelists, they're not really consciously saying, I need to have these five elements or the way that you work. I'm friends with many, many, many writers. And one thing we've noticed over time is that often your first book or your first published book is just steeped in a lot of this stuff, especially like the pleasure type stuff, the gossipy stuff.
A lot of it ends up there, you know, if you've read enough books and watched enough movies, you sort of develop this innate sense for the things you like in stories. But at least anecdotally, this kind of odd thing. happens to writers if they're career writers and you're publishing book after book after book. And what seems to have happened to so many people I know and so many people I've talked to at writing conferences is that as time goes on and your level of craft develops a lot.
So you've revised a ton of books. You're thinking more about story structure and arcs and all of this other stuff. So as you're developing more as a writer, a lot of writers end up editing a lot of these things. that we would naturally include out. So a lot of writers will start worrying about, like, is this cliche? Is this overdone?
And what they end up doing, especially like after you've published books and readers read them, and you hear all these things like, I hate love triangles, or that character is too good at everything. She's such a Mary Sue. And so writers internalize these messages. And they're like, so I'm not going to do a love triangle. And I'm not going to make my character beautiful. or I'm not going to do this and that.
And I don't want to, are these tropes overused? Maybe I shouldn't use them. And so what I often do is I go to writing conferences and I give talks on these theories and what they would predict and basically say, you know, you have to stop censoring yourself and editing these things out.
So even as your level of craft is elevated, you need to get in touch with the part of yourself that wrote those early books. So, you know, stop editing out the things that you love in books, because oftentimes that's exactly what resonates with an audience. You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough to get lost.
Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water. The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or The Hilton app. and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay.
Hilton, for the stay. Hey, listeners, I'd like to take a quick moment to give a shout out to another show. Cited Podcast is releasing an ambitious new season. Cited is an award-winning documentary podcast about the politics of research and expertise. It's a reference to citation, you know, like academic citation. So it might be the kind of thing you're into. Their new season is called The Rationality Wars. It covers political and intellectual battles to define rationality and irrationality, and it does
this through in-depth documentaries touching on key moments in the history of psychiatry and psychology. You'll hear stories about crowd psychology and liberation psychology. You'll hear about historical fights over gender and sexual identity in the DSM. And you'll hear stories about political psychology, polling, public opinion, and more. You can find Cited wherever you get your podcasts or at Citedpodcast.com. That's C-I-T-E-D-Podcast.com. So I want to ask you a little bit about the research that you did when you were a working psychologist.
I mean, once a psychologist, always a psychologist. But when you were doing that as part of your job, you studied very young kids. And you found that when they were given a choice, they would prefer real stories to those that are made up. but then at some point that preference shifts. Can you talk a little bit about that work? Sure. So this is actually my dissertation work while I was doing my PhD. And I would go around to elementary schools, daycares, preschools,
bring kids into the lab. And I was interested in this idea is there's sort of this lay conception of children as being much more steeped in the imaginary than adults are. Right? You see all of this pretend to play at this age. You know, I have a three-year-old, and every morning I have to ask him what animal he is because he's never a little boy when he wakes up in the morning. This morning he was a baby mouse.
And so he just says squeak, squeak, and I'm like, oh, we're a mouse today. You know, so this is what people think about with kids. They think about pretend play. And, you know, my middle one's really into superheroes. And he is like this morning, it was, okay, who would he went in a fight between this superhero and this superhero? And like, this is literally when we sit down at dinner every night. That's what he wants to talk about.
He has a new pairing. So we think of kids as being so much more prone to the imaginary than adults. And so what I was interested in seeing is whether that was actually like born out. So one sort of school of thought was that maybe the young kids would really like make believe stories. and then as we get older, maybe nonfiction gains traction. But what we found, surprisingly to a lot of people, I think, was actually the reverse. So we had two different conditions. One, either labeled stories is, you know, this is a real story, it really happened.
Or this is a make-belief story, it's make-belief. And we controlled across participants what the description of the story is. So it's like, this is a real story about a boy who goes to the park. You know, this is a, it's really, it really happened. This is a make-believe story about a boy who plays with a ball. It's make-belief. And which one would they like? We also had a fantasy condition where it would be like,
Or this is a make-belief story, it's make-belief. And we controlled across participants what the description of the story is. So it's like, this is a real story about a boy who goes to the park. You know, this is a, it's really, it really happened. This is a make-believe story about a boy who plays with a ball. It's make-believe. And which one would they like? We also had a fantasy condition where it would be like,
this is a story about a boy who plays hide-and-seek, and this is a boy who eats cookies in outer space versus, you know, some people would get cookies versus hide-and-seek in outer space. And what we saw across conditions is that there was actually an increase in attraction to the fictional and fantasy ones over time. So the younger children were more reality biased than older children who were more reality biased than adults, typically. So for example, on the real versus make-believe stories where they're all realistic, but we're just saying, did this really happen or not, four- and five-year-olds actually statistically significantly. preferred the stories that they thought had really happened, which is, you know, super interesting as someone who works in children's literature to see because they were like, oh, they really
were more interested in a story that actually happened than one that someone had made up. The more shocking one for us was the fantasy one. So like, this is a story about someone who eats cookies and this is a story about someone who plays hide and seek in outer space. Like as an adult, The adults, when we gave them the equivalent, were whoppingly in favor of, like, if you just have a mundane everyday thing versus a magical thing, they were whoppingly in favor of the magical thing because the realistic stories were really mundane. It was like, this is a boy who goes to school versus, you know, is it school or is it magic school, right?
So adults had a pro-fantasy preference when the realistic option was really mundane. The four- and five-year-olds, it's not that they preferred the money. Monday option, but they were just totally at chance. And I remember doing this study, like putting the two books out. They didn't ever actually read the books. We just give them those descriptions. There were no illustrations on the cover. It was just the title. You point and you're like, you know, this is the book about hide and seek in outer space and this is a book about eating cookies versus this is another kid would get cookies in outer space versus high and seat. And they were completely at chance. It did not matter. You know, some of the stories I was like, surely they'll
go for the fantasy one because as an adult, the realistic ones sounded so boring to me. But the youngest kids were just completely a chance. Sometimes they'd pick the fantasy one. Sometimes they'd pick the realistic one. By the time you got to older kids, so more in that six to eight range, they were starting to show the pro fantasy preference. And then in adults, it was very strong. Another area where you did some research was around fandom and fan communities. Can you talk about that. What is fandom? What and what makes some books attract such devoted groups? I am fascinated by the psychology of fandom. I like to think of it, you know, and not surprisingly, I have a whole section in my 27 page workbook devoted to inspiring fandom too. So, you know, once I became a professor,
fandom was something I was interested in. And I ended up pulling a lot from domains other than psychology. So there's a lot of sociology work on fandom. So fandoms sort of as communities and looking at what's going on and those different things. There's a lot of studies on specific phantoms. So like the Star Wars fandom, the supernatural fandom, Star Trek, just looking at those different things. And a lot of it's just explaining to people, okay, there are these communities of people who identify as a fan of something. So it's actually not just you really like that thing. It's that you, part of your identity is that you like that thing,
and you are involved in a group or collective of people who like that thing. So those are kind of, at least in my opinion, two of the really key elements for it to be fandom. It has to involve other people for it to be fandom. So, you know, even if you're not ever meeting someone else, maybe you're there reading fan fiction, which is stories that someone else has written about the characters. Maybe you're going on a message board. Maybe you're buying merch someone else did. Maybe you're going somewhere.
You see all these stories out there, lovely stories of people who've made lifetime friendships through fandom, through connecting to something they love. So there are several things that fascinated me about the psychology of fandom. One of the first things I wanted to do was kind of figure out what are some of the sort of psychological prerequisites for being very kind of fanish or fandomy. Because there are some people who get really involved in this.
There are some people who don't, but probably would have if they'd known it existed. And there are other people who just fundamentally are like, why would anyone do this? I get this a lot when I talk about fandom to psychologists. They're like, that's a thing? I'm like, yes, it is very much a thing. And I remember I used to teach this class at OU called the Cognitive Science of Fiction in the Honors College.
And we would do, you know, different readings every week from a variety of different domains about this. And when we talked about parasycial relationships, so those one-sided relationships we form with fictional characters and we were talking about daydreaming, year to year, always did this poll. And I would say, raise your hand if you ever daydream about fictional characters. and every year, exactly half of the hands in the class would go up.
And then I'd say, okay, raise your hand if you have never daydreamed about fictional characters. And the other half of the hands would go up. And the thing that was always so interesting to me is that people who do this do it so frequently and so automatically that they cannot imagine
what it would be like to inhabit a head where this didn't happen. And people who don't do this were like, why would you ever do that? What does it even look like? They were like, I don't understand. And so it was this thing where for both sides of the equation, it was totally eye-opening for them that some of the people had that and some did.
So I started thinking of fandom, not just about the actual collective that's out there actually doing these things. I started to think about it in terms of psychological tendencies and the way we interact with stories and how there might be individual differences in some of these propensities. And so I started getting really interested in like, okay, so what are sort of the things underpinning, psychologically underpinning,
both fandom but also fan-adjacent things. So like a certain percentage of people will actually go out there and write fan fiction. So they'll write a story about meeting their favorite character or about what should have happened at a given moment, right? But a larger percentage than that will daydrain. about that in their own head. And for many, many people, there was a lot of work where people would interview
不仅是粉丝圈，还有与粉丝圈相关的事物。比如，会有一定比例的人去写同人小说。所以他们会写一个关于遇到自己最喜欢的角色或者某个特定时刻本该发生什么的故事，对吧？但比这个比例更高的人会在自己的脑海中白日做梦。而且对于许许多多的人来说，有很多关于采访同人小说作家的工作，
fan fiction writers, and a lot of fan fiction writers come into fan fiction through daydreams. So they have been daydreaming these stories about, like, I get sucked into the universe, and then I become so-and-so's honorary little brother. And that's often what people's first stories look like, is they're just externalizing what they've been daydreaming. And so my thought was that for any activity, you see where people are actually involved in fandom and out there, like, officially doing it and connecting with each other, there's probably a broader population who's doing sort of the fandom adjacent thing. So, like, maybe they're not doing
许多同人小说作家是通过白日梦进入同人小说领域的。所以他们一直在白日梦般地构思这些故事，比如，我被吸入了那个宇宙，然后我成了某某的荣誉小弟弟。这通常就是人们最初的故事的样子，它们只是在将自己一直在幻想的事情外化。所以我的想法是，对于任何活动，你会发现人们实际上参与到粉丝圈中，并在外面，比如，官方地参与其中并彼此联系，可能有一个更广泛的群体在做某种与粉丝圈相关的事情。所以，可能他们没有在做
cosplay, but maybe they really do want that Wonder Woman shirt that kind of looks like Wonder Woman. Right. And maybe they're not on a message board, like, going through all these theories, but maybe they're talking to a friend about it and really like it when a friend or a spouse or someone is watching the same show. So you can figure out what's going to do. to happen next. And so what I started thinking about is, so what are some of the underlying properties that might vary from person to person explain this? One I came up with was just emotional investment and fictional characters. So people, and it's a chicken and an egg question, but people who tend to get really involved in the stories end up very invested in the emotional
角色扮演，但也许他们真的很想要那件有点像神奇女侠的神奇女侠T恤。对吧。也许他们没有在留言板上浏览所有这些理论，但也许他们正在和一个朋友讨论这件事，并且真的很喜欢当一个朋友、配偶或某个人也在看同一个节目时那种感觉。这样你就能猜到接下来会发生什么。所以我开始思考的是，那么有什么潜在的属性可能会因人而异来解释这一点呢？我提出的其中一个属性就是对虚构角色的情感投入。所以人们——这是一个先有鸡还是先有蛋的问题——倾向于真正投入到故事中的人，最终会极大地投入到情感
characters. So is the investment, you know, does that come first? And then that drives your involvement in the stories or is it the more involved in the story you are, the more investment did you get? But it does seem like there's a prerequisite for not all of fandom activities, because there is a subset that focuses on like world and recreating models and like building the exact drones of Star Wars or something. But a huge percentage of it seems to be driven by attachment to the characters, by those parasocial relationships with the characters. But another one I was really interested in, at least insofar as you get fan fiction, was the idea of resistance to authorial authority, is what I called it. So it's like the idea that like if you consume media and you're like, well, I guess that happened.
角色中。那么这种投入，你知道，是先产生的吗？然后这会推动你对故事的参与度，还是说你对故事的参与度越高，你的投入就越多？但确实似乎存在一个前提条件，并非针对所有的粉丝圈活动，因为有一个子集专注于世界构建和重建模型，比如建造《星球大战》中精确的无人机之类的东西。但其中很大一部分似乎是由对角色的依恋、由与角色的这种准社会关系所驱动的。但我真的很感兴趣的另一点，至少在产生同人小说的范围内，是对作者权威的抵抗意识，我是这么称呼它的。所以这就像是这样一种想法：如果你消费媒体，然后你会想，好吧，我想那确实发生了。
I didn't want that to happen, but that happened. Oh, well, you know, that's the reality now. That looks very different than someone who's like, what? that shouldn't have happened. We see it often with like people who are self-proclaimed shippers, which is derived from relationships. So they ship two characters together. So they want these two characters together and not these two. So they will actually tell you, hey, author, you got this wrong. You're wrong about who she wanted to be with. She actually wants to be with this guy. You have to go back in. I get emails all the time that tell me I had a love
我不想让它发生，但它确实发生了。哦，好吧，你知道，这就是现在的现实了。这看起来和一个自称是“CP粉”（即由“relationship”关系一词衍生而来，指支持两个角色在一起的人）的人非常不同。所以他们把两个角色凑成一对。所以他们希望这两个角色在一起而不是那两个。所以他们实际上会告诉你，嘿，作者，你搞错了。你搞错了她想和谁在一起。她其实想和这个家伙在一起。你得回去改。我总是收到这样的电子邮件，告诉我我有一个爱情
channel and they tell me she picked the wrong guy, you need to go fix this. Or once I remember I killed a major character in book three of one of my trilogies way back in the day. And I got this email from a reader who was like, you actually must undo this because this was, this did not happen. I refuse to accept it. Right. And a lot of fan fiction is the source material either isn't giving you enough of what you like. So you get glimpses of the French between these two characters, but you want a story that's all about that thing. Or it's, this thing happened and I didn't like it. So I'm going to go write a story where something else happened.
线，他们告诉我她选错了人，你需要去纠正这一点。或者我记得有一次，在很久以前我的某个三部曲的第三本书里，我写死了一个主要角色。我收到了一个读者的电子邮件，大意是：你实际上必须撤销这个决定，因为这根本不应该发生，我拒绝接受。对吧。很多同人小说都是因为源素材要么没有给你足够多你喜欢的东西。所以你只能隐约看到这两个角色之间的火花，但你想要一个完全讲这件事的故事。要么就是，这件事发生了，而我不喜欢。所以我要去写一个别的事情发生的故事。
So you can also view this resistance as sort of like a tendency to play with the source text, to be like, okay, I talk about co-authoring it along with the author. So there's always a degree that happens. No two people ever read the same book. You know, you know that very well as an author. And there's some stuff in the psychology of reading, especially in the educational literature, that focuses on this and how we put stuff into the books we read. You read it through your own experiences.
所以你也可以将这种抵抗视为一种与源文本玩耍的倾向，比如，好吧，我谈论的是与作者共同创作。所以总会有一定程度的这种情况发生。从来没有哪两个人读过同一本书。你知道的，作为一个作家，你非常清楚这一点。阅读心理学中有些内容，尤其是在教育文献中，侧重于这一点，以及我们是如何将各种东西融入我们所读的书中的。你是通过自己的经历去阅读的。
You fill in gaps, all of these kinds of different things. And so I was really interested in, well, what are the things that fans are doing? So you give them a gap. They start filling it. You're not sure what's happening. You're going to theorize about what's happening next. Something you don't like happens. you're going to do this.
你填补空白，所有这些不同类型的事情。所以我真的很感兴趣的是，粉丝们都在做些什么？你给他们一个空白。他们开始填补。你不确定接下来会发生什么。你会开始推测接下来会发生什么。发生了你不喜欢的事情。你就会这么做。
And so I started making lists of, well, I want to give readers plenty of opportunities in the book to do this. So it's having the big decisions where they wish something different had happened. It's baiting gaps. And sometimes it's really simple stuff. So like in the inheritance games, the risk-taking dangerous competition guy has this giant scar down his torso. And you just don't know how he got it for multiple books.
所以我开始列清单：嗯，我想在书中给读者提供充足的机会来做这件事。比如设置重大的抉择，让他们希望当时能有不同的事情发生。比如制造空白。有时是非常简单的事情。比如在《继承游戏》中，那个爱冒险、危险的竞争者男主角的躯干上有一道巨大的伤疤。有好几本书里，你都不知道他是怎么弄到这道伤疤的。
And that's a gap that you're actually leaving there for the audience to fill. Why? Well, then the fans can go out and talk about like, how do you think Jameson got that scar? This is how I think he got that scar. I have a friend who wrote a book once and they were always referring to like that thing that happened in Peru. And you're like, what happened in Peru?
而这就是你实际上留给读者去填补的空白。为什么？因为这样粉丝们就可以出去讨论：你觉得杰姆森是怎么弄到这个伤疤的？我是这么觉得的。我有一个朋友曾经写过一本书，他们总是提到“发生在秘鲁的那件事”。然后你会问：秘鲁发生什么了？
And they'd respond with random things like, we all agreed. That monkey was perfectly trained at the time. I always think about that. It's my friend Ali Carter wrote a book. And you're like, what happened in Peru with the monkey and the this and the that? So it's baiting that. It's like where you cut a chapter. Like are you cutting it?
他们会随机回答一些事情，比如：我们当时都同意了。那只猴子当时训练得非常完美。我总是想起这件事。我的朋友阿里·卡特写过一本书。然后你会想：秘鲁到底发生了什么，怎么还有猴子和这啊那啊的？所以这就是在制造悬念。就像你在哪里切断一章节。就像你在切断它吗？
And then like sometimes I remember in, I think it was book three of inheritance games. There was this moment where the two brothers go off. And Avery, the main character, goes home. And the brothers are kind of at both in a weird emotional spot and everything. And a few hours later, they come home and they're like, caked in mud, and one of them is bleeding. And just in the entire series, you never find out what happened in those hours, because that is something I'm reading, leaving for the readers to kind of find out there.
然后有时候我记得在，我想是《继承游戏》第三本里。有这样一个时刻，两个兄弟出去了。艾薇，也就是主角，回家了。兄弟俩在情绪上都处于一种奇怪的状态等等。几个小时后，他们回家了，身上沾满了泥，其中一个人还在流血。在整部系列中，你都从未得知在这几个小时里到底发生了什么，因为那是留给读者自己去发掘的东西。
I'm also really interested in I'll look at specific fan activities. So something like cosplay, where they will actually create versions of the costumes and dress up of the characters. And you can lose hours to looking at cosplay because there are absolute artists who do incredible, incredible cosplays. So, you know, one of the items on my little workbook is, like, does the book pass the cosplay test?
我也对特定的粉丝活动很感兴趣。比如角色扮演，他们会实际制作服装的版本并打扮成角色。你会花上几个小时来欣赏角色扮演，因为有绝对的艺术家做出了令人难以置信的角色扮演。所以，你知道，我的小工作簿上的项目之一就是，这本书经得起角色扮演的考验吗？
Like, the low level of it is the Halloween test. So, like, can a 13-year-old dress up as someone from this book for Halloween? How would they do that? What does it look like? So you think of something like Harry Potter, for instance, and it's actually really easy to dress up. up as Harry Potter, even if you don't have the official gear. So even back before they had all the
比如，低级别的测试就是万圣节测试。所以，13岁的孩子能为万圣节打扮成这本书里的人吗？他们会怎么做？它看起来是什么样的？所以你会想到比如《哈利·波特》这样的作品，实际上打扮成哈利·波特真的很容易，即使你没有官方的装备。所以甚至在他们拥有所有那些
tie-in stuff, like you drew a lightning-shaped scar on your forehead, and you wore a black cloak, and you carried a stick and wore glasses, and you were Harry Potter. So anyone could throw together a costume and be Harry Potter and recognizably Harry Potter very easily. So that's a question I asked myself, like, is this a book? Like, who could they dress up as? How could they dress up as that person? Like if someone wanted to throw a theme party based on the book, I have a test, I call the theme party test. I'm like, okay, how's the book given them like a format for the invitation? So, like, I have a book coming out in at the end of July called The Grandest Game, which is a new series set in the universe of the inheritance games where it's all these people coming to win like $30 million or something very big by solving all these puzzles and riddles and games.
衍生周边之前，比如你在额头上画一个闪电形状的伤疤，穿着一件黑斗篷，拿着一根棍子，戴着眼镜，你就是哈利·波特。所以任何人都可以随手拼凑出一套服装，成为哈利·波特，而且非常容易被认出是哈利·波特。所以这是我问自己的一个问题，比如，这是一本书吗？读者可以打扮成谁？他们怎么打扮成那个人？就像如果有人想根据这本书举办一个主题派对，我有一个测试，我称之为主题派对测试。我想，好吧，这本书有没有给他们提供邀请函的格式？所以，比如，我有一本将于7月底出版的书，叫做《最伟大的游戏》，这是一部设定在《继承游戏》宇宙中的新系列，讲的是所有人来赢得大约3000万美元或非常大的一笔奖金，通过解开所有这些谜题、谜语和游戏。
And I'm like, well, to pass the theme party test, ideally there'd be like a really elaborate invitation you get to play the game. So there are these like Willie Wonka-style golden tickets. And I'm like, well, if you want to throw a grandest game party, here's your ticket. And the question is, like, what are the, what's the drink that's in the theme party test? Or what's the food? Or what do people dress us? So there's a masquerade ball so people can dress up as the characters.
我想，为了通过主题派对测试，理想情况下会有一份非常精致的邀请函供你玩这个游戏。所以会有威利·旺卡风格的金门票。我想，如果你想办一个最伟大的游戏派对，这就是你的门票。问题是，主题派对里的饮料是什么？或者食物是什么？或者人们穿什么衣服？所以会有一个化妆舞会，这样人们就可以打扮成角色。
So I kind of go through and look at a variety of these different things. in terms of the activities, in terms of what I think is going on with the psychology. And then I've also done a related amount of work that was sort of more inductive work that I did for myself on. I'd look at, okay, what are the 20 TV shows that have the most fan fiction written for them? And can I extract sort of qualitatively what those shows have in common? And so people think of fandom as being a very sci-fi and fantasy-driven thing, but the 20 shows were actually, there was no difference between sci-fi and fantasy and realistic shows. So that didn't come out statistically significant. But what did come out as
所以我大致浏览并研究了各种这些不同的事情，就活动而言，就我所认为的心理学运作机制而言。然后我还做了相应数量的工作，这更像是我自己做的归纳工作。我研究了，好吧，同人小说最多的20个电视节目是什么？我能否从定性上提取出这些节目共同拥有的东西？所以人们认为粉丝圈是一个非常偏向科幻和奇幻的事物，但这20个节目实际上，科幻奇幻和现实主义节目之间没有任何区别。所以在统计学上并不显著。但统计学上显著的是
statistically significant was the predominance of procedural shows. So medical procedures, police procedurals, or sci-fi and fantasy that had a procedural element. So you think of something like Star Trek or supernatural, right? So those are sci-fi and fantasy. They also have a very strong procedural setup. I think once upon a time was on there, Gray's Anatomy. And so then I asked myself, well, why do I think procedural are so good at this? And I think part of the reason is that the procedural element, so the case of the week essentially takes up enough space in the narrative. So monster hunting and supernatural, the surgeries in Grey's Anatomy. And those things take up enough space that you kind of ration out some of the really juicy character moments a little more.
程序剧的统治地位。比如医疗程序剧、警察程序剧，或者带有程序剧元素的科幻奇幻剧。所以你会想到像《星际迷航》或《邪恶力量》这样的作品，对吧？所以那些是科幻奇幻剧。它们也有非常强的程序剧设定。我想《童话镇》也在其中，《实习医生格蕾》也是。然后我问自己，为什么我认为程序剧在这方面这么厉害？我想部分原因在于程序剧元素，也就是基本上每周一个的案件占据了叙事中的足够空间。所以《邪恶力量》中的怪物狩猎，《实习医生格蕾》中的外科手术。这些事情占用了足够的空间，所以你会把一些真正精彩的角色时刻稍微多分配、拉长一点。
And a lot of what people do is they're like, ooh, I want more of that. I once heard that I worked for a while in a project with one of the guys who was one of the big guys behind criminal minds. And he used to kind of call those cookies where it's the moment where they really want to see these two characters together. but it's not a show where you get to see them together all the time. And so I have a list of about 10 properties that seem to be fandom enabling. There are things like the stories tend to be temporally expansive and expand, usually into the past, though sometimes into the future in significant ways. They're emotionally expansive, meaning they, you're going to have really funny parts
人们做的很多事情都是，哦，我想要更多那样的情节。我曾经听说——我曾在一个项目中与《犯罪心理》幕后的一位大佬合作过一段时间。他过去常常把那些时刻称为“饼干”，也就是他们真的想看到这两个角色在一起的时刻，但这不是一个你能一直看到他们在一起的节目。所以我的清单上有大约10个似乎具有粉丝圈催化作用的属性。它们包括：故事往往在时间上具有扩张性，并且会扩展，通常是向过去扩展，尽管有时也会以显著的方式向未来扩展。它们在情感上具有扩张性，这意味着你会经历非常搞笑的部分
and really sad parts. It's fluff, it's angst, it's all of these different things at once. So it'll be like Buffy the Vampire Slayer. There are some episodes that were just really funny episodes. And then you have like an episode where Buffy discovers her mom's body that's just like an exploration of grief and devastating. So the things that tend to provoke fandom tend to have the whole spectrum. They're not just funny. If they're sitcoms, they're sitcoms that actually do have their sad episodes a little bit more.
和非常悲伤的部分。既有轻松甜蜜（fluff），又有虐心痛苦（angst），所有这些不同的东西同时存在。所以它会像《吸血鬼猎人巴菲》一样。有些集数真的非常搞笑。然后你会有这样一集，巴菲发现了她妈妈的遗体，这就纯粹是对悲痛的探索，极具毁灭性。所以倾向于激发出粉丝圈的事物往往涵盖了整个光谱。它们不仅仅是搞笑。如果是情景喜剧，那也是那些确实会更多地上演悲伤剧集的喜剧。
They tend to have a ton, a ton of love stories. in them, both romantic love stories, but also platonic love stories, like a brotherly love story or a friendship love story. I was thinking in Gray's Anatomy there I was talking about, that's my person, like Christina and Meredith had this friendship, and they were persons. You know, they were each other's person. And so it's the things that to be fandom provoking have all of these love stories of all kinds to give you all these relationships to get invested with. So, you know, that stuff that I left academia before I could go into a lab and test all of this in a kind of official way. But I had the theories and I had the predictions.
它们往往包含大量的爱情故事，既有浪漫的爱情故事，也有柏拉图式的爱情故事，比如兄弟之爱或友谊之爱。我当时在想《实习医生格蕾》里我提到过的，那是我的“人”，就像克里斯蒂娜和梅雷迪思有这种友谊，她们是彼此的“人”。你知道，她们是彼此的“人”。所以那些倾向于激发粉丝圈的事物，拥有所有这些各种各样的爱情故事，为你提供所有这些可以投入情感的关系。所以，你知道，在我离开学术界进入实验室以某种官方方式测试所有这些之前，我就已经做了这些事情。但我有理论，也有预测。
And so I'm able to much more informally and non-scientifically test them in my writing where I'm like, okay, what if I do all of this stuff? Both this stuff about how do you like appeal to a broad audience because you're doing how the brain is kind of really focused on stories and what kind of stories we like. and also all the fandomy stuff. And so Inheritance Games was really the first book I ever wrote where I synthesized all of that and tried to do all of that on both the fandom side of the equation and the broadly appealing side of the equation. It was just really, really deliberate about saying what happens if I do all of this in one book?
所以我能够在我自己的写作中以更非正式、非科学的方式来测试它们，我想：好吧，如果我把所有这些东西都加进去会怎么样？既有关于如何吸引广大受众的东西，因为你在处理大脑如何真正专注于故事以及我们喜欢什么样的故事，也有所有粉丝圈的元素。所以《继承游戏》真的是我写的标志着我综合了所有这些的第一本书，并试图在粉丝圈的一侧和广泛吸引力的另一侧同时做到这两点。我是非常、非常刻意地在思考：如果我把所有这些都放在一本书里会发生什么？
And it was my 21st book. So, of course, it's not just this is the only thing in the book. It has the structure. It has the character arcs. It has the plot. It has all the craft I've developed over, you know, more than 20 books. But it also has all of this stuff added in on top. And what happened is as far as experiments go, it was beyond my wildest dreams of what an experiment would look like.
而且这是我的第21本书。所以，当然，它不仅包含这些。它有结构。它有人物弧光。它有情节。它拥有我通过（你知道的）20多本书所磨练出的所有写作技艺。但它还在顶部添加了所有这些额外的内容。结果就是，就实验而言，它超出了我所能想象的最疯狂的实验梦想。
Because, again, I had published 20 previous books. And I kind of had an idea of what it looked like when I published a book. I had never hit a bestseller list. I had never really had a huge fandom. I was kind of what they call in publishing a mid-list author. So I was able to have a career. I was publishing one or two books almost every year from the time I was very young until now. But then I put all of the science in this book and I wrote the inheritance games.
因为，再次说明，我已经出版了20本书。我对出版一本书时的情形大致心里有数。我从未登上过畅销书榜。我从未真正拥有过一个庞大的粉丝圈。我在出版界被称为“中档作者”。所以我能够维持一份职业生涯。从我很年轻的时候直到现在，我几乎每年都会出版一本书或两本书。但后来我把所有这些科学原理融入了这本书，我写了《继承游戏》。
And suddenly it did hit the bestseller list and spent, you know, as a series, it spent more than 80 weeks on the series list up there with like, you know, HagerGaves and Harry Potter and Winpy Kid and Percy Jackson and like just even being on a list with all of those series. I was like, what is happening there? But I really do, you know, there's a lot of, in any publishing thing, there's a lot of luck involved and timing. Then you have to have a brilliant publishing team who's making the right packaging decisions.
然后它突然真的上了畅销书榜，并且作为系列，它在系列榜上停留了80多周，和《饥饿游戏》、《哈利·波特》、《小屁孩日记》、《波西·杰克逊》等作品并列，甚至能和所有这些系列一起上榜，我都觉得：这到底是怎么回事？但我真的认为，你知道，在任何出版事务中，都有很多运气和时机的成分。然后你必须拥有一个出色的出版团队，他们做出正确的包装决策。
So there are, of course, many other variables at play. But in terms of what I did differently, this book, It really did boil down to the science of it. Well, it's just amazing how you've really applied what you know as a psychologist to becoming the writer you are today. And it's very, very impressive. So I just want to ask one question, which is you've left academia. But what do you think are the most interesting questions out there for psychologists who are still looking at the psychology of fiction? That is a great question.
所以，当然，还有许多其他变量在起作用。但就我在这本书中所做的不同之处而言，它确实归结为科学原理。嗯，你真的把身为人心理学家的知识应用到了成为今天的作家的道路上，这真是太令人惊叹了，非常、非常深刻。所以我只想问一个问题，那就是你已经离开了学术界。但对于那些仍在研究虚构作品心理学的心理学家来说，你认为目前最有趣的问题是什么？这是一个很好的问题。
And I have a huge list somewhere of the things. You know, it hits me on a daily basis where I'm like, oh, I want. wonder. And back when I had my lab, anytime I suddenly started wondering about some of that, I could just go in a lab and I could develop the study and I could test it. And then oftentimes I was wrong about what I thought would be true and I'd discover something else. I think there is a big gap. So the area I've been playing in theoretically and testing in my writing in terms of what people like in stories, I think that's actually compared to some other areas understudy. currently. So again, I have all these theories. I put it in my writing. I really only ever did
我脑海中某处有一个长长的清单。你知道，它每天都会击中我，让我觉得：哦，我想知道。以前当我还在实验室时，每当我突然开始对其中的某些事情感到好奇时，我就可以直接走进实验室，开发一项研究并对它进行测试。然后很多时候，我对什么是真的这一设想其实是错的，而我会发现其他的东西。我认为这里有一个巨大的鸿沟。所以我一直在理论上探讨并在写作中测试的领域，即人们在故事中喜欢什么，与一些其他领域相比，我认为目前其实研究不足。所以再次强调，我有所有的这些理论。我把它写进我的作品里。我实际上只做过
one study that actually tested empirically a lot of these theories. I did a study on book titles and whether or not the words were buzzwords created by one of the theories of why we like fiction versus whether they were like a controlled word. And we did find in that study that the titles that were based on, I think, four or five different theories about why we liked fiction. All of those theories were generating titles that people were more interested in reading the book than we actually used words that had already appeared on the New York Times list. So words that should have been compelling, but they outperformed all of those. But that was the one study we did on that.
一项真正以实证方式测试其中许多理论的研究。我做过一项关于书名的研究，看看这些词是否是根据我们为什么喜欢小说的某种理论所创造的流行语，还是说它们就像受控词汇。我们在研究中确实发现，那些基于（我想是四到五个关于为什么我们喜欢小说的不同理论）的书名。所有这些理论产生的书名，都比我们实际上使用已经出现在《纽约时报》榜单上的词汇更能激起读者阅读该书的兴趣。换句话说，那些本该很有吸引力的词汇，被它们给比下去了。但那是我们在这方面做的唯一一项研究。
And I think it would be a really fascinating area for people to look into because it really does seem to be an area where it's not like there's just one theory that explains it all. It really does seem, at least from that first experiment we did, like it wasn't like only one theory predicted good words. We tested multiple different theories. So we tested the gossip theory, the pleasure theory, theory of mind theory. We did one on morality. And like all of those different domains were actually outperforming controls. So it seems like it might be an area where the, big picture of why we like stories may lend some support to a bunch of different theories, kind of all operating at the same time, which could then also be very interesting in terms
我认为这对于人们来说将是一个非常迷人的研究领域，因为它似乎确实是一个这样的领域：并不是只有一个理论能解释一切。至少从我们做的第一个实验来看，似乎并不存在只有单一理论能预测出好词的情况。我们测试了多种不同的理论。所以我们测试了八卦理论、愉悦理论、心智理论。我们还做了一项关于道德的研究。所有这些不同的领域实际上都表现得比对照组更好。所以这似乎是一个这样的领域：我们为什么喜欢故事的宏观图景可能会为一系列不同的理论提供某种支持，这些理论似乎都在同时运作，这反过来对于
of those theories themselves. So, like, is there a synthesis of a lot of these theories where it's not just, is it this or is it this? But maybe it's some combination of those things. And maybe the reason that we like stories so much is that it's this synthesis of a lot of different things coming together to kind of make this perfect storm. And then I would also say the psychology of fandom, again, where you're actually testing. Before I left, one of my graduate students was doing a study on cosplay, where you'd actually like come in and you'd dress up as either a hero or a villain. And then we were testing a bunch of things, but embedded in those are moral things to see,
这些理论本身也非常有趣。所以，比如，是否存在对其中许多理论的综合，即不仅仅是“是这个还是那个”？也许它是这些东西的某种结合。也许我们之所以如此喜欢故事，是因为它是许多不同事物结合在一起，共同形成了这场完美的风暴。然后我还要说粉丝圈的心理学，同样地，你需要去实际测试它。在我离开之前，我的一个研究生正在做一项关于角色扮演的研究，你会真正来到实验室，打扮成英雄或反派。然后我们测试了一堆东西，但其中嵌入了道德相关的东西，以便观察：
like, does your moral perspective change if you're wearing a Voldemort costume instead of a Harry Potter costume. I had a student when I left who was looking at daydreaming about fictional characters, which some of those studies have, there's some fascinating stuff that's been done out there on that, but pushing it further. And there are, when I was last in academia, there were, we were starting to see work. A lot of it was coming from graduate students. As like there, we saw, I was seeing a lot of stuff that was a master's thesis or, you know, an upcoming PhD student who was looking at actually testing some of these things about the psychology of fandom. I think oftentimes it's people who are either involved in fandom themselves or at least
如果你穿着伏地魔的服装而不是哈利·波特的服装，你的道德视角会改变吗？我离开时有一个学生正在研究对虚构角色的白日梦，关于这方面已经有一些迷人的研究成果被做出来了，但还要将它进一步推进。而且，自我最后一次身处学术界时起，我们开始看到相关研究的出现。其中很多都来自研究生。正如我们所看到的，我看到了很多硕士论文或即将毕业的博士生所做的研究，他们实际上在着手测试关于粉丝圈心理学的一些事情。我认为通常这些人要么自己就是粉丝圈的参与者，或者至少
know the ins and outs of it really well. And they were coming up with some really fascinating stuff. So I think in the years to come, I'm really interested in sort of seeing that generation of students taking off to really see sort of this field that was really, in some ways at its beginning, really start to flourish once these people who were driving it, who were so young and early in their careers, advance a little more. Well, Dr. Barnes, I want to thank you for joining me today. This has been a lot of fun and learned a lot about writing fiction. And now it's time for me to go work on my book. Well, thank you so much for having me. Like I said, I love talking about psychology, so this was an absolute class.
对里面的门道非常了解。他们提出了一些非常迷人的东西。所以我认为在未来的几年里，我真的很有兴趣看到那一代理学生起飞，真正看到这个在某些方面还处于起步阶段的领域开始蓬勃发展，一旦这些推动它前进的、如此年轻且职业生涯初期的年轻人再取得一些进展。好的，巴恩斯博士，我要感谢你今天能来到这里。这非常有趣，我也学到了很多关于写小说的知识。现在是时候让我去写我的书了。非常感谢邀请我。就像我说的，我喜欢谈论心理学，所以这绝对是一场精彩的体验。
You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.w.combeckycology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get podcasts. Then if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills.
你可以在我们的网站 www.apa.org/podcasts/speaking-of-psychology 上，或者在苹果、Spotify、YouTube 或任何你获取播客的平台上找到往期的《心理学访谈》节目。如果你喜欢我们的话题，请订阅并给我们留下评价。如果你对未来的播客有任何评论或想法，可以给我们发送电子邮件：speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学访谈》由莉·威纳曼制作。感谢收听。我是美国心理协会的金·米尔斯。
Enjoy more ways to save at Ralph's, like low prices in every aisle. And when you download the Ralph's app, you can clip and save more with digital coupons every week. Plus, you can earn fuel points to save up to $1 per gallon at the pump. At Ralph's, you can enjoy more ways to save and more rewards every time you shop. so it's always easy to save big every day with savings and rewards. Ralph's SoCal for over 150 years. Savings may vary by state. Fuel restrictions apply.
在拉尔夫超市享受更多省钱方式，例如每个过道都有低价。当你下载拉尔夫应用程序时，你可以每周通过数字优惠券剪切并节省更多。此外，你还可以赚取积分，在加油时每加仑最高节省1美元。在拉尔夫超市，你每次购物都能享受更多省钱方式和更多奖励。因此，通过节省和奖励，每天省大钱总是轻而易举。拉尔夫南加州店，150多年来陪伴左右。省钱金额可能因州而异。加油限制适用。
See site for details. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请查看网站了解详情。本期节目尚无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。